le grand défi du déconfinement sera de
restituer un maximum de liberté tout en
conservant un taux de reproduction
effectif
rt en dessous de 1 comme on en a déjà
longuement parlé ces deux variables sont
critiques pour éviter un chômage massif
et une grande instabilité politique et
pour garder la pandémie sous contrôle et
nous dispenser d'un second confinement
plusieurs variables clés permettent de
piloter ce compromis comme la production
de tests pour identifier les individus
infectés la communication scientifique
pour encourager les gestes barrières et
la distanciation physique et la
notification à l'exposition pour alerter
les personnes à risque cependant la
variable la plus importante et la plus
efficace pour garder rt en dessous de 1
ce sera certainement la mise en
quarantaine de tout individu contagieux
tel est le coeur de la stratégie
recommandé par l'organisation mondiale
de la santé à savoir tester tracé est
isolé we're going to make a wish we
continue to call on christophe un test
isolate anne claire pour fabriquer entre
abricots mais bien sûr la grande
difficulté de la stratégie de mise en
quarantaine des individus contagieux
c'est que ces individus contagieux sont
très difficiles à identifier
surtout s'ils sont prêts symptomatique
comme on l'a vu dans une vidéo
précédente au mieux dans la plupart des
cas on ne pourra avoir que des
suspicions de contagiosité
il va alors falloir agir dans
l'incertitude
aujourd'hui on va justement s'intéresser
à la stratégie de déconfinement optimale
sachant cette incertitude
mais pour commencer cette vidéo
supposons que par un coup de baguette
magique il été possible d'identifier
exactement
l'ensemble des individus contagieux quel
serait alors une stratégie de mise en
quarantaine optimale on pourrait croire
que la stratégie optimale serait alors
de mettre en quarantaine tout individu
contagieux et oui on a fait ça aiderait
beaucoup mais en fait il n'est pas
indispensable de mettre tous les
individus contagieux en quarantaine oui
car le plus d'importance n'est pas
d'isoler tous les contagieux le plus
important ça semble davantage de
maximiser la liberté de la population
tout en gardant rt en dessous de 1
or il n'est pas nécessaire que les
individus contagieux soient tous en
quarantaine pour garder perte est
inférieure à 1
supposons ainsi que le rt des individus
contagieux en quarantaine soit égal à rt
quarantaine de l'ordre de 0.5 alors que
le rt des individus contagieux or
quarantaine sachant les masques les
gestes barrières et l'immunité de groupe
est égal à air libre qu'ont estimé de
l'ordre de 2,5
si une fraction alpha des contagieux
libéré de la quarantaine alors le rt
global sera une moyenne pondérée de r
quarantaine et aire libre et plus
précisément et gala alpha x air libre +
1 - alpha x air quarantaine pour avoir
rt inférieur à 20 il suffira alors
d'avoir alpha x air libre - r
quarantaine plus air quarantaine
inférieur à 1 ce qui équivalait à dire
que alpha doit être inférieur à 1 - r
quarantaine / air libre - r quarantaine
qui avec les nombres que j'ai considéré
est égale à 25%
et ça c'est vraiment une très bonne
nouvelle ça veut dire qu'il est inutile
de mettre tout le monde en quarantaine
pour contrôler la pandémie un contagieux
sur quatre peut être or quarantaine ou
dit autrement il suffit que trois
contagieux sur quatre soit en
quarantaine en particulier ceux ci
pourra nous permettre d'autoriser la
circulation de ceux dont le travail est
important comme le personnel médical les
épidémiologistes où les employés des
chaînes de production des biens de base
surtout si ceux ci sont difficilement
remplaçable et sinon aucun symptôme
al'inverse noter que air libre dépens en
pratique du comportement des individus
un individu très précautionneux du port
de masques des gestes barrières et de la
distanciation physique aura un taux de
reproduction plus faible qu'elle
vu qu'ils respecteraient mal ses
consignes pour réduire et arte il serait
alors prioritaire de mettre le second en
quarantaine et noter qu'il ne s'agit pas
là d'un jugement de ce second individu
en aucun cas je suis en train de dire
qu'il mérite d'être en quarantaine il
s'agit là de ce qu'il serait optimal
si tout ce qu'on veut faire c'est
maximiser la liberté tout en gardant rt
inférieure à 1
bon après il se trouve que les
incentives serait aussi pas mal alignée
dans la mesure où autoriser davantage la
circulation des individus prud'hon
augmentera d incentive à être prudents
qui est pas si mal
c'était le cas à cette liste où l'on
pouvait identifier les individus
contagieux malheureusement en pratique
tester si un individu est contagieux est
une tâche très difficile en fait même
les tests pourraient ne pas suffire à y
parvenir
en effet comme on l'a vu la dernière
fois il semble y avoir un haut taux
d'échec dans le prélèvement nasopharyngé
qui pourrait aller de 15 à 50 %
mais alors même s'ils ont testé tout le
monde le test naso pharyngé pourraient
échouer à détecter 3 contagieux sur
quatre est donc à mettre suffisamment de
contagieux en quarantaine et ça c'est
dans l'hypothèse où l'on extrait tout le
monde peut être toutes les semaines or
même avec les tests groupe et qui
apparemment bizarrement sont illégaux en
france
testé toute la population française tous
les jours pour être encore être
déraisonnable s'appuyer uniquement sur
des tests pour des conflits nés pour
être en fait être insuffisant ou du
moins cela semble sous-optimale
derrière cette déficience des tests se
cache un problème plus fondamental qui
est l'archétype de la différence entre
le raisonnement fréquentes east et le
raisonnement bayésiens alors je ne vais
pas rentrer dans le détail de cette
distinction
d'autres vidéos le font très bien mais
en bref ce n'est pas parce qu'un test
assez fiable dit quelque chose que vous
devez le croire par exemple imaginer que
deux membres de votre foyer ont été
testés positifs et que vous avez tous
les symptômes du code vide mais votre
test est négatif
devez-vous alors conclure que vous
n'avez pas le coc vide certes la
vraisemblance du résultat du test
négatif en supposant que vous êtes covit
positif est faible cependant la
vraisemblance de la donner ici le
résultat du test n'est pas la crédence
de la théorie ici le fait que vous êtes
infecté un test seule ne suffit pas pour
conclure sans préjugés aucune conclusion
ne peut être tirée
ainsi pour un bayésiens le préjugé
bayésiens qu'il fallait avoir avant de
connaître le résultat du test importe
tout autant que la vraisemblance de la
donner avant de voir le résultat du test
qu'est-ce qui était judicieux de penser
ou se situer votre curseur de turing où
placez-vous vos crédence en le fait
d'être qu'ovide positif si de membres de
votre foyer ont été testés positifs et
si vous avez des symptômes
alors il est très probable a priori que
vous soyez vous aussi qu'ovide positif
ainsi ce curseur penche alors
probablement très largement en faveur
d'être qu'ovide positif a priori mais
alors même un résultat négatif du test
pourrait être insuffisant pour penser
que vous êtes qu'ovide négatif ce
résultat du test cette donnée va
déplacer le curseur
mais en fonction du degré de fiabilité
du test ce déplacement pourrait être
insuffisant pour déplacer suffisamment
le curseur pour vous rendre la théorie
covit négatif plus crédible que la
théorie qu'ovide positif et puis surtout
ce résultat du test sera probablement
insuffisant pour ramener le curseur de
turing très loin faire la théorie
qu'ovide négatif malgré un résultat
négatif du test la probabilité d'être
qu'ovide positifs pourraient demeurer
non négligeable notez que ce
raisonnement est particulièrement
important à avoir quand il s'agit des
tests sérologiques qui teste votre
immunité contre coheed surtout si vous
n'avez jamais eu de symptômes
caractéristiques du coc vide
a priori non vous n'êtes pas
immunisé contre qu'ovide donc même si
ces tests sérologiques affirme que vous
êtes immunisés et même s'ils sont
valides à 95%
il peut rester probable que vous n'êtes
pas immunisé contre qu'ovide en effet a
priori seulement autour d'une personne
sur vingt dans la population a été
infectée donc à priori vous avez une
cote autour de 1 contre 20 d'être
immunisé maintenant dans la théorie
qu'ovide immunisés un test qui affirme
que vous êtes immunisés n'est aucunement
surprenant alors que dans la théorie
covit non immunisés un test qui affirme
que vous êtes immunisés et très
surprenant mais ce n'est pas
complètement surprenant ça arrive 5% du
temps soit une fois sur 20 le rapport de
surprise est donc deux fois vent et donc
à posteriori une cote d'attributs nisé
et 20 fois un conte revin ce qui fait du
vin contre 20 ou si la plaie du un
contre un vous dit autrement
malgré un test valide à 95% qui dit que
vous êtes immunisés vous avez seulement
une chance sur deux d'être effectivement
immunisés
le raisonnement probabiliste invite
surtout à tenir compte de toutes sortes
de données pour estimer votre
probabilité d'avoir locaux vides au lieu
d'être obnubilé uniquement par un test
comme le dit le proverbe bayésiens
l'apprentissage est une danse chaque
donnée devrait faire danser vos curseur
de turing est le cumul de petits
déplacements peut compter beaucoup plus
qu'une données particulières typiquement
la simple augmentation du nombre de cas
confirmés dans votre région devrait
suffire à augmenter la probabilité que
vous soyez covit positives de même votre
comportement quotidien devrait affecter
votre estimation de la probabilité que
vous soyez covit positif si vous vous
êtes enfermé chez vous et faites très
attention à garder de mettre des
distances vis-à-vis de tout autre être
humain lors de vos sorties
alors votre probabilité d'être co lead
positif devrait rester faible
cependant ces signaux pourraient être
insuffisants pour estimer adéquatement
la probabilité d'avoir le coc vide
de nombreux autres signaux intéressants
mériterait certainement notre attention
comme l'analyse des égouts les
applications de notification à
l'exposition voir peut-être les
applications d'analystes dont
instruments sonores de votre tout qui
semble s'expliquer par la manière
particulière qu'a locaux vides
d'attaquer nos poumons
et puis bien sûr même un autodiagnostic
de vos symptômes devra affecter vos créé
dans ce sens le fait d'être qu'ovide
positif même si n'oubliez pas que le
gros problème reste les contaminations
près symptomatique c'est à dire les
contaminations par des individus
contagieux qui ne sont pas encore
capables d'inférer leur état de santé à
partir de leurs symptômes
même si aucun de ces signaux faibles ne
suffit à conclure définitivement quoi
que ce soit le cumul de tous ces signaux
peut vous aider à mieux estimer votre
probabilité d'avoir le coc vides et
alors idéalement il faudra effectuer le
calcul bayésiens pour bien estimé cette
probabilité
malheureusement ce calcul est impossible
à effectuer de manière précise il va
donc falloir se contenter de l'estimé
mais étant donné le manque de
centralisation de ces données la
difficulté du raisonnement probabiliste
pour nos cerveaux de primates n'est pas
sorti de l'auberge
imaginons toutefois qu'on dispose d'une
estimation pour chaque individu de la
probabilité qu il est le co lead sa
chance et probabilité à quoi
ressemblerait un déconfinement optimale
qu'il faudra t-il à leur mettre en
quarantaine et bien de façon remarquable
si l'objectif est de maximiser la
liberté de la population tout en gardant
rt en dessous de 1 et en supposant pour
commencer que tous les individus
contagieux contamine autant de personnes
qui soient en quarantaine ou hors
quarantaine la solution optimale pour le
déconfinement est en fait très simple il
suffit de fixer un seuil p quarantaine
tels que tout individu dont la
probabilité d'avoir le coc vide est
supérieure à ce seuil devra se mettre en
quarantaine
autrement dit rester chez soi si le
risque d'être contagieux sachant toutes
les données à disposition écran
c'est en fait une solution optimale
ok on va
montrez l'optimalité de cette stratégie
juste parce que bon ça me manque un peu
de faire du match et en plus ce sont des
geôles du mat qui mêle optimisation
linéaire et formule de bise mais bon si
vous n'êtes pas à l'aise avec ça je vous
invite à sauter directement à la section
suivante de la vidéo appelons pédauque
eu sa chance et la probabilité qu'un
individu contagieux c'est soit mise en
quarantaine
q pour une grande population où les
probabilités vont être similaires à des
proportions
le taux de reproduction effective sera
environ rt est égal à probabilité de cul
sa chance et fois hercules plus la
probabilité de q bar sa chance et fois
rlq bar correspond à l'absence de
quarantaine rt peut alors être réécrit
percu plus
rl - hercules fois probabilité de cuba
re sa chance et donc pour rappel il faut
garantir que ça restera en dessous de 1
par ailleurs la probabilité du liberté
est égale à la probabilité d'être hors
confirmant ses dires paix de cuba en
tenant compte de l'ensemble des données
des sur un individu et on s'autorise ont
des décisions xd de mise en quarantaine
qui dépendent de d le problème du
déconfinement optimale est alors de
maximiser la somme des probabilités de
cuba sachant dès fois la probabilité de
des sous la contrainte et recule plus
rl - hercules fois la somme les
probabilités de cuba sachant dès fois
probabilité de dé sa chance et de tous
inférieurs à oran où les variables de
décision sont en fait les xd est égale à
la probité de cuba sachant des délices
des étangs des probabilités
on a également la contrainte que les
hits et honnête entre 0 et 1 le problème
du déconfinement optimale quel con la
modéliser ici est alors un problème
linéaires c'est à dire un problème dans
la fonction objectifs et dont les
contraintes sont des fonctions affine
des variables de décision xd en fait il
s'agit d' une relaxation linéaire du
fameux problème du sac à dos où il faut
remplir un sac à dos de contenus de
valeur sachant que le sac à dos ne peut
porter qu'un certain poids total maximum
sauf que à la place de m un objet dans
un sac à dos on autorise ici un individu
à la circulation pour mieux comprendre
ce problème on peut remplacer les
variables xd par d'autres variables mise
à l'échelle
y des étés gala xd fois profité de d la
fonction à maximiser devient alors tout
simplement l'asean t il régler la
contrainte sur le taux de reproduction
effectif
elle s'écrit alors la somme d y des fois
la probabilité de des sachants c'est dit
c'est par la probabilité de ces tout ça
devant être inférieur à 1 - hercules /
rl ou hercule noter aussi que la
contrainte qui dit que l'équité soit
entre 0 et 1 se traduit en une
contrainte il dit que les grecs doivent
être entre 0 et la probabilité de d en
appliquant la formule de baise qui dit
que la probabilité de ces sachants des
est égale à la probabilité de des
sachants cette fois la probabilité de
ces / la probabilité de dés et donc de
façon équivalente que la probabilité de
des sachants c / la probabilité 2d est
égale à la probabilité de ces sachants
des / probabilité de ces on se rend
compte que la contrainte s'écrit sous la
forme la somme d y day fois la
probabilité de ces sachants des doit
être inférieur à un certain budget ou le
budget de cette contrainte est égal à 1
- hercules / rl - hercules le tout fois
la probabilité de ces qui de façon
critique est une quantité indépendante
et des variables de décision ainsi à
chaque fois qu'on augmente d'une unité
une quantité y des on augmente de 1
notre quantité de liberté dans la
population mais on augmente aussi de
probabilités de ces sachants des le coût
en termes d'impact néfaste sur le taux
de reproduction effectif pour maximiser
la quantité de liberté dans la
population
il est alors optimale d'augmenter en
priorité les quantités y des pour
lesquels les coûts sur la sécurité du
déconfinement est faible c'est à dire
ceux pour qui la probabilité de ces
sachants des est faible en fait il faut
ainsi remplir notre sac à dos de liberté
jusqu'à ce que notre contraintes
deviennent saturé c'est à dire jusqu'à
ce que rt soit égal à 1
voilà qui est équivalent à fixer un
seuil et a exigé de ceux dont la
probabilité d'être contagieux excède ce
seuil de se confiner
on vient de démontrer que le confinement
optimale consiste à confiner ceux dont
la probabilité d'être contagieux est
plus grande
le modèle combien d'autres
et très simplifié mais il peut ensuite
être complexifier en prenant que
notamment différents facteurs
par exemple comme on l'a vu plus tôt on
peut inclure dans notre modèle des
contributions différentes à la
production et à la livraison des biens
de base comme la santé ou la nourriture
et là encore on peut exploiter les
données des pour estimer cette
contribution de différents individus
ainsi on chercherait désormais à
maximiser quelque chose comme la somme
des eu des fois xd fois la probabilité
de thé ou eu des est égal à l'espérance
de lui sachant d et cuba est la
contribution espérer des individus
libérés ayant des données d typiquement
1 infirmière biologistes ou un livreur
de biens de base aurait sans doute un eu
des plus élevés que la moyenne
de l'autre côté on peut inclure des
risques de contamination différents en
fonction des données d ainsi un individu
dont les données suggèrent qu'il prend
extrêmement souvent des gestes barrières
et de la dispensation social serait
associé à une valeur de rl et deux
hercules plus petit en appelant rld rqd
les nombreux moyens de contamination
d'un individu aux données des cils et or
quarantaine et s'il est en quarantaine
la contrainte sur le taux de
reproduction effectifs s'écrit désormais
sommes des rqd probabilité de des
sachants c'est plus la somme des rld -
rqd fin xd pour la probité de dé sa
chance et doit être inférieur à 1
le problème reste alors une relaxation
du problème du sac à dos cependant cette
fois la quantité clé pour décider de la
mise en quarantaine sera la probabilité
d'être contagieux sachant des données
des fois rld - rqd le tout divisé par
user ainsi un individu probablement
contagieux qui gagnerait beaucoup à être
confinés et qui contribuent peu à
faciliter l'accès aux biens de base au
plus grand nombre serait davantage mises
en quarantaine en tout cas si l'objectif
est quelque chose comme la restitution
d'un maximum de liberté tout en gardant
la pandémie sous contrôle un autre point
très important et que j'ai considéré
jusqu'ici uniquement des données des
publics en pratique par souci d'anonymat
il est critique de protéger les données
personnelles néanmoins on peut aisément
démontrer le théorème suivant il veut un
compromis inéluctable entre liberté du
plus grand nombre et protection des
données personnelles
en effet plus les données publiques des
sous nombreuses - les données
personnelles sont protégés mais plus il
est possible d'avoir plus de liberté
sous la contrainte un taux de
reproduction effectif inférieur à 1
de façon très intéressante avec ce
modèle il est possible de
avantage quantifier ce compromis enfin
une dernière difficulté qui n'est pas
des moindres celle que j'ai supposé ici
que l'on pouvait prendre facilement une
décision de mise en quarantaine
centralisée et que celle ci serait
respectée en pratique la
responsabilisation de la population et
critique surtout si seuls les citoyens
disposent de beaucoup de données les
concernant
c'est pourquoi la diffusion de la pensée
probabiliste est ici critique une
population plus responsable et plus
compétente pour effectuer des
estimations probabiliste pour décider
soi-même adéquatement de se mettre en
quarantaine ou non c'est une population
qui pourra s'offrir beaucoup plus de
liberté tout en gardant la pandémie sous
contrôle
aujourd'hui on a présenté un modèle très
simplifiée de déconfinement optimale
l'objectif ici n'était absolument pas de
proposer un projet très précis
malheureusement en pratique effectué un
déconfinement sécurisé c'est déjà très
très très très difficile htc compliqué
et malheureusement notre modèle jouer
montre qu'il ya un compromis inéluctable
à trouver entre restitution des libertés
protection des données personnelles et
responsabilisation individuelle
la bonne nouvelle toutefois c'est qu'on
semble pouvoir optimiser les trois axes
à la fois en promouvant et en appliquant
beaucoup plus la pensée probabiliste en
effet pour optimiser un déconfinement
sécuriser les tests ne suffiront
probablement pas il sera alors sans
doute préférable de croiser toutes
sortes de données mais surtout pour un
déconfinement optimale la manière de
croiser ces données doit se conformer
autant que possible avec les lois des
probabilités et en particulier la
probabilité d'être contagieux sachant
toutes ces données est vraiment une
information critique pour des confiné de
manière optimale puis il s'agira de
restituer en priorité liberté de ceux
dont la probabilité d'être contagieux et
faibles dont les précautions sanitaires
sont grandes et dont les contributions à
foner davantage accès aux biens de base
sont grandes
telle semble être la direction à prendre
pour un déconfinement optimale